auch der ukrainische präsident seelands
gerhard heute auf einer geheim- presse
vor konferenz gesprochen holzhammer ist
jetzt auch bei uns im studio zumindest
digital ist er ab jetzt auch die ganze
sendung dabei ich sehe hier neben mir
und deswegen vielen herzlichen dank an
peter helfe die einschätzung und jetzt
möchten wir natürlich auch direkt die
einschätzung von paul ronzheimer hören
und paul erzähle uns darauf bitte von
dem was sie lenski heute in der geheim-
pressekonferenz gesagt hat
janina es war sicherlich eine der
ungewöhnlichsten begegnungen die ich
jemals in kiew hatte und zwar deshalb
weil ich schon häufig in diesem
präsidenten gebäude war 2014 häufig
petro poroschenko interviewt ab dann
selensky bereits interviewt ab aber als
ich dort heute hin kam mit wahnsinnigen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen und dann in
dieses präsidenten gebäude gegangen bin
war das licht ausgeschaltet man ist fast
über die treppen gestolpert weil zu
dunkel war dann lagen sandsäcke überall
das muss man sich so ein bisschen
vorstellen als würde im kanzleramt
plötzlich kein licht mehr scheinen und
olaf scholz sich irgendwo verstecken und
auf geheime wege werden dort
journalisten reingebracht damit es eine
kriegs pressekonferenz geben könnte das
war so ein fall dann saßen die
journalisten einzelne eingeladenen
journalisten in diesem raum der wiederum
relativ normal aus aber dann kam sie
lenski dort rein und er machte einen
trotz dieses krieges trotz dieser
persönlichen bedrohung auch für ihn
selbst denn er steht ja auf einer
todesliste ganz weit oben an platz eins
wahrscheinlich von wladimir putin haben
sich einen stuhl und hat sich direkt vor
die journalisten gesetzt er weiß
natürlich wie inszenierung funktioniert
als ehemaliger schauspieler auch als
präsident mittlerweile weiß er dass wie
man mit bildern umgeht aber es war so
einen unterschied zu den bilder die man
von wladimir putin kennt auch die
pressekonferenz oder die ansprache die
putin vor hingehalten hat wo er wieder
gedroht hat und gesagt hat der krieg
geht weiter wo er gesagt hat dass er die
ukraine für nazis hält und deswegen die
russen und ukrainer vereint werden
müssten und die nazis bekämpft werden
müssen diese absurde
schwachsinn ist zu nett ausgedrückt
diese grauenhaften lügen die wladimir
putin über die ukraine verbreitet und da
gegen sie lenski der mittag gegenüber
saß und wir kennen uns von früheren
interviews und ich habe ihn dann gefragt
hajo und salz gehört nur gesagt nur bett
und hat mir die hand gereicht und wir
haben kurz die hände geschüttelt und man
erlebt einen präsidenten der wirklich
über sich hinauswächst und er hat dann
wieder sehr klar adressiert was
notwendig ist aus seiner sicht er hat
klar gemacht dass das land kämpfen wir
dass ich nicht aufgeben werden er hat
gesagt wenn er nicht präsident wäre dann
wäre er auch in einer zivilen
verteidigungs einheit er hat gesagt dass
er unterstützung will eine no fly so und
sicherlich eine unrealistische forderung
dennoch hat er das klar gemacht und er
hat einen satz gesagt den ich ja sehr
wichtig finde vielleicht auch jetzt hier
für die diskussion er hat gesagt wenn
putin dort nicht gestoppt wird wenn es
nicht geschafft wird putin in der
ukraine zu stoppen dann sind die
nächsten länder die baltischen staaten
und irgendwann steht putin dann in
berlin er hat gesagt er stünde dann
würde bis zur berliner mauer gehen also
er meint sozusagen das ehemalige ost
berlin das sind dinge die vor monaten
janisch andere politiker gesagt haben
aber nachdem all das wahr geworden ist
was ja die größten pessimisten wie wir
vielleicht und andere angenommen haben
was putin machen würde hört man ganz
genau hin wenn dann diese sätze kommen
das kann ich mir absolut vorstellen paul
und es ist also ich weiß gar nicht was
man dabei empfindet wenn man zu so einer
geheimen pressekonferenz geht
christoph denn es ist alles auch sehr
wahlen ukraine konflikt dass das paul
gerade erklärt hat wir haben gerade über
die no fly sohn gesprochen sollten wir
die umsetzen das an der etwas heikle
frage weil es auch öl ins feuer gießen
kann aber ich kann die argumente des
herrn botschafters sehr gut
nachvollziehen weil die russen ja nicht
nur militärische angriffe verüben wie
sie selber in ihrer propaganda behaupten
sondern leider auch sehr viele angriffe
auf zivilisten
vornehmen krankenhäuser mittlerweile
bombardieren nicht ganz normale
wohnhäuser
unschuldige menschen und dieses treiben
was putin da mittlerweile seit gut einer
woche macht diesen treiben kann man
nicht zu sehen deswegen halte ich schon
für notwendig dass wir dieses thema auch
stärker hier in den fokus der deutschen
und europäischen
politik nehmen aber es ist eine
schwierige abwägung das muss man auch
klar sagen weil putin ja mittlerweile
auch sogar mit atomaren angriffen droht
ganz bewusst auch dieses
schreckensszenario aufbaut und wir alle
wissen noch aus der zeit des kalten
krieges wenn einer meint falschen knopf
drückt oder irgendwo was ausrutscht dann
kann es ganz schnell zu einer großen
katastrophe führen deswegen ist im
moment das wirklich sehr sehr schwierig
auch die richtigen entscheidungen zu
treffen ich wollte noch einmal auch paul
ronzheimer fragen der da wirklich im
moment
im wahrsten sinne des wortes an der
front steht und auch wirklich
hervorragenden journalismus macht ganz
live dabei ist ich hoffe auch dass er
dafür einen reporter preis und
journalisten preis bekommt das hat er
auf jeden fall verdient aber mich würde
mal interessieren
was die ukraine weiter an waffen braucht
oder wie sich das auch in den nächsten
tagen möglicherweise entwickeln könnte
denn als vor gut einer woche putin mit
dem angriff begonnen hat da haben in
deutschland ja sehr viele gesagt
defensivwaffen an die ukraine zu liefern
das bringt ja gar nichts mehr weil das
sowieso nach zwei oder drei tagen alles
vorbei ist und jetzt sehen wir die
ukraine die haben da wirklich ein hilft
heroischen kampf die kämpfen wie die
besten die machen das super und es gibt
ganz viel unterstützung auch aus der
welt und mittlerweile ja auch die
hoffnung dass die ukraine den kampf
vielleicht sogar gewinnen können was man
von einer woche nie gedacht hätte
inwiefern würden weitere defensiv
waffenlieferungen helfen das würde mich
noch mal interessieren weil das ja auch
für die entscheidung hier in deutschland
von großer bedeutung ist
ja bloß nicht ob sie sprechen da einen
sehr wichtigen punkt an und zunächst
einmal muss man sagen das glaube ich
ganz viele politiker zum beispiel frau
strack zimmermann von der fdp und andere
die gesagt haben und in einer zynischen
art und weise gesagt haben naja jetzt
ist das ja so und die russen haben eben
eine militärische übermacht und was
sollen wir denn noch hin liefern ich
glaube diese politiker die sollten sich
ganz dringend bei anderem mit dem
ukrainischen botschafter entschuldigen
und frau strack zimmermann ist da nicht
die erste nicht die einzige da können
noch ganz viele dazu kommen auch von
ihrer partei und von der spd die sollten
gesammelt dort bei der botschaft
vorstellig werden bei aller dynamik und
sich entschuldigen bei ihm denn erst der
mann der über monate lang immer wieder
gesagt hat wir brauchen diese waffen
laut und deutlich hat er das gesagt
niemand wollte ihm zuhört niemand aus
dieser politik hat ihn wirklich ernst
genommen niemand hat sich dem angenommen
und das ist für mich eigentlich ein
skandal denn noch aufgearbeitet werden
muss aber jetzt ist es so wie es ist und
was gut ist muss man sagen ist das
wieder waffen gekommen sind aus
deutschland und wo geht ist vor allem
das muss man den zuschauern auch
erklären es geht vor allem um die abwehr
von raketen die abwehr von
marschflugkörpern es geht um flugabwehr
das ist ja etwas was putin bislang
zumindest in kiew noch nicht eingesetzt
hat er hat ja alle möglichkeiten aus der
luft hier so zu bombardieren wie er zb
aleppo bombardiert hat und dann kann ich
ihnen sagen bleibt von dieser stadt
nichts mehr übrig dann wäre hier alles
schutt und asche und dann reden wir über
zehntausende und hunderttausende tote
ich wollte was einwänden gegen den
begriff der defensivwaffen den kann ich
nicht mehr hören die gefahr ist doch
nicht dass die ukraine russland an
greift also dass man sich also auf
kleinwaffen beschränken muss die ukraine
muss möglichst wirkungsvoll bewaffnet
werden und elias bei einer
flugverbotszone zu luft kämpfen zwischen
nato flugzeugen und russischen
flugzeugen kommen lassen das wäre der
gang in den in den atomaren krieg glaube
ich in einer riesen eskalation muss die
ukraine in die lage versetzt werden
durch moderne
waffensysteme nicht nur durch schulter
gestützte
kleinraketen die auf flugzeuge
abgeschlossen werden soll natürlich
richtige wirkungsvolle luftabwehr
batterien sich zur wehr zu setzen und
die müssen natürlich an allen größeren
städten seien und es wird höchste zeit
dass die geliefert werden ob die
ursprünglich für defensive oder
offensive aufgaben gedacht ist mir
völlig wurscht sie müssen wirken und ich
möchte den begriff von defensivwaffen
nicht mehr hören die ukraine wird
russland nie angreifen
wenig es ist auch ihre meinung dazu wir
haben gerade vor dieser sendung habe ich
eine lange lange liste eine neue liste
von den waffensystemen die wir gerade
jetzt brauchen an das
verteidigungsministerium und an das
auswärtige amt geschickt und da ist die
frage von defensiv oder offensiv waffen
nicht so relevant wir verteidigen uns
seit acht tagen wir sind auf unserem
boden wir haben nicht vor jemanden
anzugreifen und auch nicht vor die
gebiete die bereits vor diesem angriff
übersetzt waren von russen die creme und
donners auch nicht zurückerobern mitteln
warfen aber was wir wollen wir wollen
das leben der zivilisten schützen wir
wollen
wir wollen die systeme zum beispiel
bachelot oder ketten also die die
hartmann hier in deutschland wir werden
jetzt auch ins baltikum versetzt das
braucht man auch um die verbündeten zu
schützen aber vielleicht gibt es auch
eine überlegung das was kommt als erstes
also wir sind jetzt schon angegriffen
worden und das heißt dann müssen wir
nicht nur jetzt die vielleicht so sehr
die bundeswehr oder das
verteidigungsministerium in pflicht
nehmen sondern auch die deutsche
rüstungsindustrie
wir führen jetzt gespräche war es da
noch geliefert werden kann kurzfristig
um um die menschen zu schützen aber auch
dann vielleicht auch mittelfristig um
die verteidigungsfähigkeiten zu zu
stärken in der ukraine und das werde
auch die botschaft an putin wo er dann
vielleicht doch davon absieht meine
meine lieblingsstadt weg auf meine
heimat zu zwei bomben via laptop oder
wie andere städte die schon ihrem
schicksal
liegen mussten deswegen danke für diese
unterstützung wir wir brauchen das wir
wir hoffen dass die bundesregierung sich
nicht so viel zeit nehmen wird um diese
liste zu prüfen es muss schnellstens
reagiert werden das heißt wir erwarten
eine antwort in den nächsten tagen bevor
ich jetzt zu meinem thema komme weil das
ist bei für den 8 gleich gewesen dass
jeder etwas mitbringt kann was ihn
aufregt habe ich noch eine letzte frage
1 hennig und ich wünsche mir nur einen
namens hören also einen namen eine kurze
antwort herbolzheim halt eben
angesprochen politiker sollten sich bei
ihnen entschuldigen wer von wem erwarten
sie denn eine entschuldung gibt es einen
politiker wo sie sagen ja das stimmt der
sollte sich wirklich mal entschuldigen
nein also ich die branche erwarte man
keine entschuldigung man erwartet
richtiges handeln und das ist das was
ich erwarte also wir haben über
zeitenwende jetzt alle gehörte an diesem
sonntag in der sondersitzung des
bundestages aber vier tage sind
vergangen und es ist noch bei uns
zumindest nicht angekommen ja dieses
land diese antwort herr wenig gibt es
denn einen der so richtig daneben lag wo
sie sagen also dieser politiker der
hätte sich schon mal anders äußern
können
es ist eine viel zu lange liste und die
sendung würde vielleicht zulange dauern
wollte es war dann ja nicht nur
politiker es waren viele menschen die
einfach nicht glauben wollten auch wir
wollten nicht glauben das ist nicht so
dass wir irgendwie
apokalyptischen bundesregierung anfangs
die gesamte regierung massiv und das
betrifft auch die die krokos dass ich
auch die die vorherigen regierungen weil
hätte man diese schritte im jahre 14
nach der creme annexion
eingeleitet und hätten man uns bewaffnet
dann wäre es werde zum vielleicht zu
diesem krieg in diesem ausmaße gekommen
und dann glaube ich dass wir doch immer
noch in einer friedlichen ukraine leben
würden aber wie gesagt es ist schnell
von gestern heute zählt das was heute
diese nächsten tagen geschieht was die
regierung macht welche waffen wir
bekommen können und zwar sehr schnell
dass er richtig sie habe nur gesehen die
ukraine sind bereit sich zu verteidigen
das ist die grosse und von der sie auch
mit einer großen tradition gebrochen
werden müssen wir ja schon sagen dass
die waffen hilfe aus dem westen immer zu
spät kommt immer zu spät
also immer eine phase zu spät jetzt wo
die großen städte gedrängt werden
müssten doch längst radargestützte
luftabwehrsysteme dort sein um die
städte zu verteidigen vielleicht kommen
sie irgendwann aber dann weiß ich nicht
in welchem zustand kirche
[Musik]